today's Wednesday january fifteenth and
this is gamespot news I'm Chris waters
here for one more day of substitute new
zing Jess MacDonald is back tomorrow but
until then you're on mine sorry that was
creepy legions of publishers pundits and
players have all sounded off about the
battle of xbox one vs. playstation 4
specs and now the word from Microsoft is
a pretty much the same speaking with
Australia's game planet Microsoft's
australasian vice president of sales and
marketing Alan Bowman said it's not the
power of the xbox one or ps4 that will
make the difference but rather the games
from just a pure specs perspective it's
always going to be a fairly marginal
difference Bowman said the purists are
going to argue the toss but I think it
comes down to the games Bowman spoke
about expanding the number of
territories where the Xbox one is sold
as well as pushing the appeal of the
system beyond the current state of quote
absolutely as male and core skewered as
you can imagine I don't know Bowman
there's not a picture of a sports
athlete on the Xbox one and it doesn't
have a beard and it's not a truck so i
think my imagination has you beat there
a developer only conference hosted by
valve called steam dev days kicked off
today with the news that Gabe Newell
wants to give the red light to green
light yeah according to a tweet by hot
blooded games CFO Dave ashrey Newell
said our goal is to make green light go
away not because it's not useful but
because we're evolving what the next
incarnation of steam greenlight might be
we don't know I just hope there's still
room for games like cat lateral damage
just look at that little fella go more
details have emerged about quantum break
the new xbox one exclusive from Alan
Wake developer remedy
head of franchise development askari ha
Canon spoke to edge about the two
intertwined ways that players will
experience the game the best experience
would be to play the game watch the live
action then play the game some more but
if you've chosen to dedicate your two
hour slots and gaming and you don't want
to watch live action straight away you
can continue on with the game and pick
up the live action from your iPad or
phone at a later date remedy CEO
Matthias mill arena added my gut tells
me they'll play a section of the game
they'll watch live action with a beer or
coffee and then jump back into the game
so were these live action bits just
glorified cutscenes I mean I know
they've talked about player choice
influencing how they play out and all
but how do you see this all panning out
let me know below metal gear solid 5
ground zeroes is apparently coming along
quite nicely as creator Hideo Kojima
tweeted a picture of the ps4 game
running on a PS Vita using remote play
ground zeroes will be a standalone
prologue chapter two metal gear solid 5
the phantom pain and according to Kojima
will serve as a bridge between the
series traditional linear path and the
more open structure of phantom pain last
in probably least some new merchandise
for Xbox one owners excited about
titanfall it's a controller the design
was inspired by an in-game weapon
apparently and it'll be available when
the game comes out on March 11th I think
it looks kind of cool let me know what
you folks think in the comments below or
by tweeting using the hashtag GS news
I've had a fun stint guest hosting this
time around and if you're curious what
else i do on the site be sure to check
out the steam early access feature video
series that's running all this week
thanks for watching have a great day